so as I understand you started this
project because you had a personal
interest in the subject is that the case
yeah I grew up in Philadelphia and I
think due to the nature of the incident
and how traumatic and tragic it was for
the whole city
but also due the fact that I was 11 so I
was roughly the age of some of the
children that died in the house and I
was also at that age where you're really
sort of susceptible to those events that
happen outside it was one of the first
events that I remember that sort of came
from the news that really impacted my my
feeling of well-being if you will my
feeling of safety it really frightened
me as another child living in that city
and I think it just impacted me I didn't
have the sort of ways that adults have
to frame these things and understand
them better to me it was just it was
just frightening like this happened to
me scary and then when I moved away not
that long after you started to talk to
people your age and peers and you
realized this thing that affected you
was largely unknown to other people my
my age and I've talked to over the years
a lot of people across the country and
it's just not that well known among
Americans so I think that sort of added
to it for me and then ultimately I went
to film school and studied documentary
and you you know in film school you
learn a really specific way to sort of
approach these things and process and a
rubric for what makes a good film so it
was sort of this trajectory where it was
like it bothered me as a kid it bothered
me more as a young adult that no one
knew about it and then as a slightly
older young adult I sort of finally had
the tools and the the methods to sort of
approach it through through going to
film school and then beyond that it
still took a long time and I needed an
institutional partner in GW at George
Washington University and and then
ultimately working with knowles and
making the decision to cut this type of
archival film
I personally am fascinated by the way
you have chosen to use only archival
footage in a story that could be told in
a variety of ways how did you make that
decision was that something that else
was involved with I think nose was so
important to that decision that I like
to let him go first on this one i when
when Jason brought the film to me
usually as an editor he come on close to
the end of production but I
Jason had all this footage that he'd
been collecting for years and years and
several interviews contemporary
interviews with the subjects and birdie
Michael Moses ward was one of them James
Burke hired the police officer at the
end was one of them the who are the
other ones Ramona oh yeah Ramona and I
watch these interviews and what struck
me about them is something that maybe
strikes me about this whole subject is
that I don't think anybody understands
what happened now any better than they
did at the time of the incident
and so these interviews were they were
people talking about this now but almost
without much benefit of hindsight people
didn't have a lot more to say about this
so then when I watched the Commission
footage I saw boy this is so it was
surprisingly cinematic with great
lighting and great close-ups and you
know people under pressure to answer
questions why did they have close-ups of
the girl you did you put those in close
the gap no they did a great job
producing this they had cameras lined up
for everything and you know they had a
whole multi camera suite I'm sure
directors you went on for 20 days or so
the Commission so we had lots of lots of
footage of all sorts I got the sense
that the actual production people that
worked on it kind of had a sense of the
moment that that these are guys that do
a lot of sort of you know newsy
public-access c type stuff and here was
this time where it was
I think they sensed it in the same way
and realized it was time to step up to
the plate and and bring their bring
their a-game and saw it as sort of a
creative opportunity or almost a
historic creative opportunity that's the
sense and then we picked that up you
know 25 years later and said we can take
this what they've made and use this
footage the the commissioned footage to
you know give the context and to keep us
in that time period and I suggested that
to Jason and and luckily we agreed that
we thought it was something that we
would give a shot we we thought it was
kind of risky and we said let's let's
try it I mean I think in in some ways it
it puts you into that moment in 1985 but
then in other ways it allows you to draw
your own conclusions from what's going
on I think
we had contemporary interviews in this
it would be certainly about the story
that occurred there but this way you can
see it as what happened on Osage Avenue
in 1985 or you can see it as a parable
for a lot of other things a lot of it
hinged around an archive that was a
Temple University in Philadelphia and
what had happened was the Commission not
everything but not everything you see
but a large portion the Commission as
they were doing their work they went to
the news stations and they asked for the
live tapes as evidence and then all of
that became part of this sort of cache
of stuff that included the well it's a
little more complicated than that but it
included the transcripts and the actual
hearing tapes and these news tapes that
were collected and they were all seated
to a university where they were held in
the library but they were sort of held
under lock and key for a lot of years
and you could sort of you sort of look
but not touch and they were sort of
behind glass and it took a large part of
the battle and I was getting things from
other sources and people were giving me
tapes and and sort of you know minor
stuff but a lot of the time making the
film had to do with negotiating the big
cache of footage out from the archive
that was rather protective of it and
wanted to make sure that they didn't
release it in a way that would cause
legal trouble or I think in a broader
sense caused the story to be told in a
not careful way that's part of archives
nature is famous so the people well and
I should say too what would actually
broke that logjam was going to another
university and joining the faculty of
the George Washington University that
was very very supportive in terms of of
getting the access and negotiating those
deals and it's sort of an interesting
story to me in terms of institutional
support but also you know when I was on
the outside trying to get this access I
really resented that and you know why do
I need this sort of stamp of approval to
make this film but then once you sort of
get on the inside and you do the work to
sort of build a build a career build a
reputation you sort of you know I'm
actually a different person than I was
when I was first trying to access and
you think well maybe there's something
to jumping through those hoops and and
becoming sort of you know making your
bones if you will and getting that
support that you it forces you to
develop in a certain way and gain the
support and sort of
the story in a responsible way